[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible one-of-a-kind hilarious Miss
Pat I'm so glad I've known her uh here
and there we've run into each other our
paths have crossed over the years she is
incredible I'm fine I'm glad we finally
got to sit down and have a long-form
chat can't wait for you to hear here is
a little taste part is for you we don't
use powder that's right black people
smoke crack yeah I don't like that I'm
the example of whiteness but I mean I'm
just sitting there I'm sitting across
from yeah if there was another white guy
we could have gestured well I could say
her name is going skiing if you know
what I mean what she does a lot of coke
oh I don't believe that
the Miss Pat show is three seasons of
hilariousness it's on BET plus right now
check that out and if you'd like to see
something I am up to what am I up to I
am on the road if you want to see me do
stand-up comedy go to petehomes.com I am
coming up in New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Wisconsin Royal Oak
Michigan Minneapolis Minnesota New York
New York and Ridgefield Connecticut I
will be adding some new dates as well
tickets for all of those dates will
always be at petehomes.com or follow me
on Instagram I'm always tweeting
tweeting yeah I tweet on Instagram igram
on Twitter it's just something I do but
I'm always sending out those links so
check that out if you want to see me
live or if you're going to be in the Los
Angeles area go to
largo-la.com we had to postpone the one
in March unfortunately due to a shooting
conflict with a TV thing I'm doing but
May 4th is the next one in Los Angeles
go to largo-la.com for that if you're
going to be in the LA area all right
everybody that's all I gotta plug enjoy
this chat with the one and only Miss Pat
get into it you can put your shoes on it
sit like that I'm gonna put my shoes on
because somebody gotta help me put them
back on I'm good no don't take them off
just put you put your shoes on no Pete
this is how fat people say it no I can't
do that
who the [__] you saw do that Bert
Kreischer he he I'm telling he was
rushed to the emergency room after he
did what now he was rushed to the
emergency room after he was sitting like
you he can't sit like this oh no it'd
take a lot of stretching before this you
can't be lounging like I'm painting your
portrait the whole time here here take
this one we're gonna at least prop you
up properly there you go there you go
okay there you go all right
how do you how does that feel
like I want to go to [__] sleep
this is a great big I'm a big person
you're a big person this is our couch
he's a deep if you seated with no bone
and no no wrong when you just relaxing
oh you're I thought you were pointing
out that I today I'm not wearing a bra
oh that's just me okay these are the
ABCs of me well some I don't hey this is
California y'all get to be free here so
are you do you live out here hell no
where are you are you I'm in Atlanta
you're in Atlanta I was just there
where was I in Atlanta
what was the venue called you was
performing there I know because I saw
something yeah I was performing in
Atlanta
um I can't remember the name of it
though but I've been all over Atlanta
Winery Winery that sounds right yeah I
think yeah
entering like a 600 or something like a
minute I don't know that wasn't no no
okay I know I saw you coming to town
yeah I asked everybody I'm gonna ask you
you're from Atlanta I was like what is
Atlanta I asked a lot of people in
Atlanta I was like what is it you know
like you say like what's Chicago they're
like deep dish pizza
mustaches white socks and cubs you go
like name any City you could say [__]
Orlando people be like well Disney World
we got like swamp lands then I'm like
what is Atlanta what is Atlanta oh tell
me what it is lemon pepper wings sweet
tea okay soul food yeah I like lemon
pepper wings I haven't heard that you're
talking about the white side white
people Stadium hot dogs with sauerkraut
I like that you're you're reading my
Eastern European okay
[__]
it's a crowd on a hot dog thank you and
is it is it a segregated place it seems
like no it sounds very diverse I lived
in Indiana for 15 years and I was blown
away by the segregation I'm like why
don't y'all live out here in Plainfield
it's like oh it's too white I said but
the school system is awesome crime you
know I was shocked that's the premise of
your show you really lived in India I
really lived in Indiana and why did you
go to Indiana my husband worked at
General Motors okay and when I moved to
that little small town Plainfield I was
like money separate I mean money
separates you in Atlanta yeah okay in
Indiana they were separated it was a
whole like mixed people if you was if
you was had a mixed child or you was a
mixed couple you lived in fish you if
you was white and Military there was a
mixed race area I swear it was it was
fishing Indiana yeah Fisher
if you have mixed parents yes playing
field was like middle class and guys was
for the super rich and uh Indianapolis
uh that was just for Poe that was for
black poor black I ain't gonna say poor
black
I'm gonna say did you say po I didn't
say I heard Poe uh it was a few
black it was it was just so like you
knew it was crazy where I don't think
there's an area in Atlanta for for mixed
race couple they just everybody just
live everywhere right but if you want to
fish you it was a lot of mixed race
cover in in India okay see that's one of
the things that I noticed and liked
about Atlanta I don't know if that's
true of Georgia as a state but Atlanta
for sure there didn't seem to be lines
like there are in Chicago Chicago is
very segregated it's like certain bus
lines certain parts of town
Chicago's so segregated you better wear
the wrong colors across the street you
mean gang Affiliates yes that's what I
mean
I sound like the NPR like subtitles Miss
Pat means gang affiliation I uh when I
play Chicago I used to play the uh the
little club downtown Zanies Zanies I
never I never left the area
yeah okay now we stayed ready near my
hotel and I just I don't know you were
afraid of Old Town Chicago no I just
stay in my [__] room I figured if I'm
in my room can't nobody snatch me can't
nobody kidnap me can't get killed and I
ain't getting no straight bullets that
didn't belongs to me I'm gonna stay in
my [__] room if you get a bud you
want to make sure it was for you uh
pretty much yeah at least make sure it
was intended I would just I'm not lying
I love Chicago is a beautiful place but
it scares me yeah like I can go to some
other place like the mon hour when
nobody really goes and just and I'm okay
yeah I I think it's because of all the
[__] that you hear on the news yeah I I
don't go outside in Chicago yeah a lot a
lot happens in Chicago I mean big city
big city big city a lot isn't happening
doesn't get reported you know what I
mean yeah a lot of people Atlanta are
the same way I mean look look we we we
got gangs and [__] too yeah so I stay on
my side of the road there too and did
you move into
um you've had a lot of success I'm
assuming you got a nice place there's
beautiful houses down there tell me
about it I didn't want to live around a
lot I didn't want to live without a
celebrities live so I just went down to
the country party and bought me seven
acres and built the house Seven Acres
yeah what that's huge
Seven Acres so you have people that work
on it like you're not keeping the land
like some a staff has to take care of
Seven Acres no my family
built a big house yes and I've built a
podcast Studio because you know I
podcast yes we're not plugging your
podcast okay I'm just kidding let's go
tell people what it's called I'm 100
joking oh the pet now so I built a
podcast Studio next to my house oh you
recorded there uh well the house is
still being built okay so I just bought
Seven Acres I had a house there and I'm
a diyer so I said you know what I'm
gonna do this [__] myself with no sub
contract I'm gonna be the contractor
just you and I went on how to architect
and I learned a lot it gave me a
headache but I'm still building to this
day did it make you realize why they
have subcontractors I don't know why
they have some contract I didn't want to
give them 10 of my budget
you never regretted it you're like I'm
glad I'm doing this like it's all
funneling through you yeah
it's not going as fast
if a contractor yeah
um it will probably move a lot of a lot
faster yes I had a lot of changes
because I I was so excited to be doing a
house this big on my own that it was
things that I left out so when the house
started to get built I was like no I
need another set of stairs no I need an
elevator no I need this and he's like
you've heard of change fees
that's the thing yes it is you're like
Tommy Lee in the beginning of Tommy and
Pam did you watch that yeah they were
doing their own house and he was like I
need a rotating water bed and stuff like
that they were the contractors hated
them yeah do you really have an elevator
in your house yeah like a service
elevator
well no service like a big ass elephant
50. so I figured from there oh it's for
you it's not like to load stuff in no no
no it's just for my family it's really
for me and my husband to go upstairs and
slap the [__] out of the kids yeah you
don't feel like using the steps that day
well you don't want to be winded oh I
will be winded no by the time you're
done yes because the slap won't won't
feel as hard so if I take the elevator
which take a half a second less than a
minute to get up there I could beat the
hell out of the kids and come on back
down God help you if the kids figure out
how to like short the elevator and stop
you so you have time to like calm down
like they'll stop you mid-floor I'm glad
they don't listen to your podcast you
don't know that you don't know that I
reach all types I know they don't
they're pretty young okay these are the
ones you adopted yeah these are the ones
I adopted from your niece the oldest is
14 the youngest is nine and you I've
heard you call them you're correct my
crack baby yeah I'm making that up and
and they're how were their ages of four
and nine no they uh nine nine eleven
twelve in 4 13 14. there's five of them
there's four nine eleven thirteen
fourteen oh I'm sorry I messed up so
how's that going are they is it I
haven't had them for 10 years yeah so
it's going pretty good this is my last
set I'm not taking care of nobody else
kids I told my family [__] y'all all
y'all kids can jump off a bounce and I'm
done what was the decision like though I
mean so your niece was struggling with
addiction yeah I picked her up one
Christmas uh I went home to celebrate
the Christmas with a side of the family
that I don't [__] with I don't know why
God tricked me he was like you need to
go spend Christmas with your mama fella
I'm like God you need to stop [__]
with me and you know he just kept saying
I need to go down there and so I go why
why did he want you to go down I don't
know why you think it had something to
do I mean you were coming up no well let
me let me back up so I'm I'm I'm riding
on 285 in Atlanta one day and I get a
phone call and it's my niece and she
said auntie I need some Pampers for my
baby so I said well where are you she
said I'm on Candler Road how about my
x-axis was Candler Road I get off at the
exit and go to this crack Motel I mean
I've it's been a while since I've it's
been years since I've seen a true
crackhead or even just dealt in drugs I
didn't even know people still live like
that scared the [__] out of me I take
her some Pampers and then the other
sister called me I thought maybe the
technology would Advance like everything
else I thought people had stopped
selling [__] stuff got off drugs you
know found something else to do I'm glad
we circled back I interrupted for that
little gem yeah but but the culture
hadn't changed you've been out of it for
a long time but there it was over 20
years still doing it but doing it the
same way the same way yeah yeah and so
then my other niece called and said well
can you help bring my kids something to
eat so I go over to a hotel and there's
my niece in there pregnant with a third
a fourth child and got three crawling
around on the floor and I was like well
she was like my boyfriend got arrested
for armed robber I said well he gonna be
there for a while because they usually
keep them so just come on and live with
me well you made the choice then and
there well I was just trying to help you
know hoping that she said no and she
said no and I was like I did my [__]
part she said no I did an empty gesture
like you're like I can help you move but
with four kids and but she said no she
said no so she gave birth to the baby on
November 28th and I had set up Christmas
to go visit and by this time she had
moved in with some people that didn't
want her and my my cousin uh was like
please take her and I ended up taking it
I was like oh Lord you don't trick me
and [__] God why you do this to me and
so she wasn't even there a year she ran
off
oh that's how it happened yes and I went
and got full custody because I was gonna
give I was gonna put them in the system
but I had had the baby since she was two
weeks old yeah and the baby was just
starting to walk you know by this time I
love a [__] baby yeah so I just can't
go drop the baby off yeah so I said okay
I said God why you do this to me and I
never forget this Pete uh voice
whispered in my ear and say keep them
and I got you and my whole life changed
tell me about this voice please tell me
I swear it was the voice of God you know
everybody hear different things but was
it did it seem like outside of yourself
like it sounds like my voice like it was
it was it was I don't even want to say
it was a male voice it was a warm voice
yeah and it but it wasn't just in your
head it wasn't in my head by the way it
could be in your head it
was you needed an external voice for a
life change this big can I say last time
I was in Charlotte the woman who drove
me was an all black woman car service it
was called like pink boots or something
it was it was amazing they drove me too
and from the airport anyway she was
telling me I was like why are you still
in Charlotte and she was like her mom
was there and she was standing in her
bedroom and she heard God's voice and I
said the same thing I was like was it an
external voice and she was like yes it
was so this voice is going around and
making people move back to their mom's
Hometown and adopt four kids that's a
big deal well you better be an external
voice no they came to Indiana I brought
them to Indiana with me okay and we all
just moved back to Atlanta but you know
I wasn't gonna keep those kids I I mean
I was I was really working hard to get a
comedy career out the ground I was doing
okay
um and I just did my kids was grown my
kids was getting ready to graduate my
last two were just gonna be done I was
gonna be done I was gonna be free just
me and my husband I love how honest you
are by the way everybody else would be
like and you know they're beautiful
children oh no and you're like I don't
want no I didn't [__] want them kids
and I tell people all the time I I love
them but I didn't I didn't want them but
they mom I mean it's honest and then I
put them in school and I fell in love
with them and I'm like well [__] every
child
you know we can't pick our parents and
to me for coming from where I came from
every child deserves to start off on a
solid foundation yeah now you get if
your child [__] up their foundation and
break and crack it at least you can say
they beginning was was solid yeah
because I know my beginning wasn't solid
right and I know what I went through
with having a crumbles up under my feet
so I was like having a blood under your
feet crumbles crumbs or break I don't
[__] know I just want to make sure I
understood that you said crumble yeah
you try to walk away but you crumble
it's amazing concrete is all broken and
no no [__] Foundation piece I had no
Foundation to stand up I wasn't calling
it to question what you said well I'm
here to listen to you I love that if she
laughing I made up the word she laughed
I made of the word it's crumble word
yeah crumble's a word oh crumble okay
Jasmine knows this is good you and it's
the right word you grew up in a rough
situation and that had to inform that
had to open up your heart while you
wanted that was you know that wasn't my
first set of keys that I raised that was
like my fourth set
you have your biological kid and then I
had my sister-in-law kids and then I had
my uh my sister kids and then I had my
um I had these kids okay then you can
say whatever words you want and I'm
gonna say you know what I mean it's like
if you're raising four sets of kids and
I wasn't I wasn't even I don't even
think I was
35 I wasn't even 25 and I had already
raised two sets of kids I don't know
three sets of keys you're like a
superhero or something yeah I was a damn
fool but you also see when I heard that
you uh took in your niece's four kids I
assumed your your train had already come
in show business-wise you were still
trying to make it yeah tell me what's
that look like if you're going out on a
weekend and now you got these four kids
you know my daughter was in the my
daughter was a senior I think and
excuse me she was getting ready to um
graduate and she wanted to go to HBCU so
when I brought my niece in who was still
on drugs but I didn't really know it
because I got a job got her clean taught
her how to drive bought a car everything
you taught her how to drive okay got her
glasses got by I I've never seen a human
being and I'm not [__] talking about
my niece well yes I am I took her to the
dentist and they pulled 18 teeth I said
[__] you only got 32 no 18. they pulled
18 teeth that's more than half I'm doing
the math right now that's a lot I don't
I don't know how the [__] did you even
open your eyes with 18 raggedy ass teeth
in your mouth and and it was a rush to
get them pulled because she was on
Medicaid so I was like can you get them
all pool you know she got a job never
her health care of them kicked in but
she's still on Medicaid so you know the
least they can do when you're on
Medicaid is pull them so they pull all
the [__] Teeth did they give her fake
teeth if she's just walking around they
was all in the back of her mouth so she
was able to chew like a bunny rabbit
with the fur on her teeth will you stop
it yeah I mean
she nibbled she became a Nibbler only
well now she became a hoe only more of a
hoe cause I got him rotten teeth out of
mouth she can suck dick without a jaw
hurting I can't yes and this premise
she used to have a toothache all the
time and it's hard to suck a dick with a
toothache no yes no you can't when your
teeth hurt
don't say it's hard to suck a dick with
a two things it's gonna be your YouTube
it can't be it can't be they'll block it
they'll block it yes okay so they took
out most of her teeth you got her
glasses how was that really she is a kid
that had the same site she cannot
[__] see it all so I ended up getting
her glasses I bought a cosign for her
car help I got a job you know ticket she
on the right track but somehow
crackheads five other crackheads and she
found what a crack was in Indiana and so
I had got her an apartment and
everything and she just [__] gave it
all opposite
I'm gonna go get myself together
and so when I called defects and asked
him to help me they wouldn't even
[__] help me they told me where the
kids are aren't in danger you got food
in the refrigerator
so they weren't worried about it no
because you were there but they were
like technically she didn't abandon the
kid I was like yes she did these kids
did not come out of my vagina she
abandoned these [__] kids and he's
like no the house looks safe y'all got
grocery we'll see you later
wow that's incredible and then they told
me I could get a check for 235 what the
hell is 235 gonna do for uh four kids
two of them can share half an iPod
oh iPod the one that word when you
turned it on yes so did you get that one
you know I ended up keeping them they're
doing great now and when you would go on
the road or something oh I was telling
you about my daughter she was getting
ready to graduate she's gonna go to HBCU
but when I got one that mama left my
daughter was like I'm not leaving my
father here with all these kids so she
chose to go to college at home which was
uh she went to
um Purdue okay which is um she did the
online yeah so she went Chicken College
no
she went to there and I think she did
Ball State online and she ended up
getting both of her degrees and my son
was in high school at the time two days
so they just stayed home and helped
raise and they would help that's nice so
and because
doing getting where you are in comedy
hard enough yes impossible yes it's
impossible like I don't know if it's
impossible it's very difficult so to do
it with all of these other things going
on yes and also to come where you came
from before we get into that because
you've told that story a lot so I'm
going to try and ask you things you
haven't been asked okay I always feel
like George is a like a like a scary
place in the in the haunted spiritual
way you ever see a ghost no I've never
seen a ghost
no you would be who I would want to see
a ghost if somebody was going to see a
ghost I would like to see your reaction
to a ghost because it would be hilarious
I really there's some people I'm like
let me say this that you beat any black
people or action until it go well this
is what be hilarious this is what David
Blaine has figured out yeah what
who goes I'd be like hell to the [__]
no no
and we begin
the white people I'm like so what kill
you ma'am and what century are you from
you don't even put the [__] ghosts oh
yeah on your podcast I don't got the
[__] up
what about psychics any anything ever
happened to you so let me I got a second
tell me your psychic story so my
daughter tells me right and I know you
remember this so she's you know before
Bob Saget passed away we became you know
I talked to him all the time yeah well
really yeah what a sweetheart
um I didn't put it out there and three
down and then like that you know he came
to my house for dinner and we would talk
like it did a little work a little late
work you were like I don't have a
contractor Bob you got to earn your keep
can you help me nail some Nails no I
just I just talked to him all the time
and we went out to dinner it's just a
comedy River
that's the name of the show these rips
aren't helping my daughter go to a
psychic right right a couple days after
my daughter was talking to this damn
psyche so she tells me she said Mama the
the psyche said Bob second died from a
heart attack I say what [__] psychic
and so then she tells me then she tells
me she's sending this thing she said
you've been Birkin burping a lot and I
said yeah how you know and so she was
like the psychic said that you have a
spot on your lung scared the [__] out of
me don't send me [__]
um was it a spot
she don't send me all of these pictures
that the psychic sent her right he's
drawing them no like colored pencil
sketches like it's somebody it's like
she's saying this is where so she sent
me a rib cage and say it right here is
what a doctor need to look really scared
[__] I mean I go into the doctor say my
daughter went in to a psychic and
psychics say I got something going on
with me it's red here so the doctor
looked at the the skin he said do you
have stage four cancer because that's
what that is I say what the [__] she
paid this [__] five dollars and later
we give him five to charge or five
dollar every time she talked to him and
just don't send her something right and
then when I googled this image it was
straight off the internet oh my God and
I cursed my daughter the hook out
she don't do [__] she read the article
before y'all do and act like she know
the information oh my God so this is not
a good psychic is that before Bob passed
no that was like the day of the day
after he passed and they were oh it was
a heart attack so what are you talking
about so that is also found less
foundless yes you know you would have
been thinking about it that's what
everybody assumed it was a heart attack
right right I'm like what are you
talking about I said how did they even
know I knew Bob Saget but the lady you
know how they when you easy to [__]
manipulate out of five dollars at a time
you know this one told me I had cancer
let the man said man this is stage four
Council and this person got to be dead
this is really bad
you took the scan into the you're not
listening to me he's like no you're not
listening to me so okay this is
unbelievable I'm glad I asked you for
your psychic story I know I'm gonna jump
a little ahead in your story that it was
a um it was a social worker somebody
told you you should do or your
caseworker told you you should do stand
up yeah tell me the story of the first
time you did stand up because that had
to first time what did you talk about
and what did you know about it I know
you know now you've been doing it a long
time but when you're just starting we
don't know anything so what was Miss Pat
like the first time you went up and
you're like my caseworker said I should
do this the first time well she well you
know it stayed in my head when you know
when somebody said well you should try
something so I got my girlfriend that
lived around a corner for me I said look
I really want to try this stand-up
comedy out you know and my neighbor was
always edging me on too so I said I said
I'm gonna try to stand up comment I said
if it don't work and they don't like me
because I had I started going to the
comedy club in Atlanta back in those
days you can go Monday through Sunday
every day of the week that was some type
of Open Mic or something and he would go
and watch I would just go and watch I
would just go and watch nobody knew I
wanted to be a comedian I wanted to see
it's always the best advice just go and
watch a little bit see what it looks
like see them do the same act twice I
went for six months watching just
watching and so finally I got the
courage up and I told my friend I was
like let's just go up to this little
place called The Pub and it was near my
house because I lived in Riverdale and
the little put was in Morrow it's a
little bar
and I went in there and I signed up for
open mic and um I was so [__] scared
so I started drinking Coronas and I
don't even [__] drink no beer and it
was this white girl and I just showing
her ass and I went in there wait what
what just acting a [__] Fool on the
stage no just in the audience drunk okay
and so I started off with the first joke
I ever told which my brother was a
professional cat burglar and we used to
Breaking people houses but one day he
kicked in somebody's door a little old
lady sitting there watching like price
is right and he was like freeze [__]
I'm the FBI and snatched the TV and we
ran out the door
good night that was a very expensive
oxygen that was a fair first joke I ever
told is it true yeah it was a true story
that's the first news report you ever
gave like you did anyway
oh and she's like the FBI needed to
seize my television for an important
okay the [__] she said we didn't look
back this is like when me and my friend
Opie stole our first Playboy my job was
to distract the clerk so you were
basically the me in that situation and
the other guy was the Opie who actually
stole the magazine you know what I mean
yeah it was the easier job
he's kicking he's yelling I think when
my brother was picking up the TV I was
unplugging it while she was just like
what the [__] job the unplugger is
very important try and do that Heist
that scam without someone to unplug the
TV see how far you go
so that did it work
yeah my brother always broken people
houses that's how we got school clothes
and food and you know [__] like that you
know he that's what he did you go to
work we kick your doing and you went
with him that was something yeah I
needed pamper money so if I got things
like
um if we if we this is probably 30 years
ago so
um oh well I've been married 30 years
probably 40 years ago wow so I had one
child at the time and my child is there
is 34.
so if we needed stuff like school
clothes or money or you know we were
Basics we were still stuffed like right
I would go in there and like still
detergent pamples if they had any you
know go in they refrigerated food
whatever you know and we what we got if
we could sell we sell right it wasn't
Catherine Zeta Jones going underneath
the lasers this was like a crime of
necessity you needed Basics yeah we need
a base and how do how are you getting in
my brother was a good my uncle when he
was a kid taught him how to pick locks
that I would never let anybody my uncle
was taught my brother how to pick locks
I never forget he started with the lock
in your hand and he showed him how to
pick that then he went to door locks
then it went to I mean went to bedroom
door locks yeah he didn't went to uh
door regular door locks yeah so my
brother could pick a [__] lock like
nobody no other this was Dimitri Martin
I think had a bit about this where he's
like what is the code of like the
ethical code of Locksmiths because they
teach you in locksmith School how to
break it down my uncle peanut taught my
brother I know Peanut no you don't
[Laughter]
dead serious no you don't you don't know
my uncle I don't know your uncle peanut
but he learned where'd he learn I I
don't know I guess you know I grew up in
a bootleg guys you learned a whole bunch
of [__] so maybe my granddaddy what were
you bootlegging my girl I didn't move
like [__] my granny is so moonshine like
real bootlegging yeah yeah not like DVDs
on Canal Street oh no this was before
this was before Electronics
the internet used to just be moonshine
that that's all people had I remember we
used to have a number man that came to
the house twice a day you could play it
it's Lottery now but you could play the
number in the daytime and you can play
it in the evening and my Grandad would
look in the look in the newspaper and
remember the peanut cartoon I know
Peanut I told you shut your ass up
I got Jasmine hey you take a uh Mike you
take one of those little micro uh scrap
what is those things that hold up to
your eye yeah
magnifying glasses yeah and he would get
the numbers out of the peanuts the
cartoon would you still do it wait what
I need help okay the Phoenix comic strip
wow
I don't know how they put them together
but but old people do this they take the
comic strip and they get a magnifying
glass and you look put your look in that
category yeah and it's all types of
numbers hanging off of those um really
also cartoon characters I swore my hand
to God go do it so my mama would play
like
you mean in the drawing
hair in the eye it could be in their
hands you just gotta know what you're
looking for so as a kid they would give
us magnifying glasses and we would look
through the cartoon and try to pick out
what the number was going to be that day
did it ever work yeah my granddad used
to hit for 50 Cent he'll win a hundred
dollars the peanut strategy yeah so
peanut butter use the comic strip to to
get the lottery numbers I did not know
this because you don't know enough black
people pee I know lots of black people
well you don't know nothing I've been
looking at peanut
you don't know me
I love it I I just it reflexively was
like I guess I do
get a magnifying glass and look in the
comment straight there's a lot of people
in the hood that's how they get their
lottery numbers wow okay oh that's how
they used to get their lottery numbers
back in the day yeah there might be a
new way now maybe it's karma Duke now
maybe it's Marmaduke now no I'm telling
you just try when you get a chance give
him a magnifying glass get the comic
strip out of the newspaper the daily
paper and look through that video
I'm surprised you never heard it you've
never heard of that well is she a
different type of black person
yeah family
go what are you doing magnifying glasses
they stop you did you ever break into a
house and it goes sideways some go wrong
one time my brother broke in the house
and um
uh I was just sitting in the car and the
homeowner came up and threw up and threw
something that was really big what was
that I ain't gonna say because the
person might hear you and he remember
really but he threw something
I'm not through some almost damn near
killed me and I never went back wow and
you're still I think the statute of
limitations is you're clear I'm probably
I'm quite sure I'm clear but you're
worried that this man might be insane
and come find you that man was pretty
old so he's probably dead right now
what do you throw
him and my brother just started shooting
at each other and I'm ducking in the
cars like Lord you make it you you help
me get out of this [__] I'm never going
again and I never won again oh so this
guy caught you breaking into his house
in a gun car broken yeah well him and my
brother because my brother always had a
stolen gun and then he shot back yeah
yeah and I think the man didn't kill us
because we were young black kids okay he
was black he made a judgment call yeah I
was like that's why he didn't kill us
it's like shoot to wound
he didn't shoot he didn't see me because
I was in the flow board I disappeared I
was like if I get out of this [__] and I
had a baby at the time right and I was
like let me tell you something I just
get my Pampers some other way
and did you did you make good on that uh
yeah
I started working at a place because
like before the Waffle House a place
called The Huddle House what was it
Huddle House okay you never heard of the
hotel most people are having Huddle
House Huddle House you're right I guess
I don't know enough black people what is
going on no it was before the Waffle
House okay three days was it yellow with
the black letters it was orange okay you
ever heard of Huddle House see Jasmine's
got my back every year she's stepping
away but it was a place called the whole
house I used to do waitressing there
okay and I would get off at five o'clock
in the morning still try to go to school
because I had a baby wow you'd work all
night oh my God catch a little nap yeah
probably in school I ain't learned [__]
till later on
oh my God so you stopped you stopped
breaking into houses though yeah I
stopped but your brother keep doing it
yeah my brother a professional Thief
until he ended up going to prison for
that
okay I don't know what the [__] you went
to prison for half the time we want to
talk to each other so I don't know why
he was in jail but he went for a long
time well you never know when he might
pop in
well he's out now
he was a home burglary gym
I think you might break into your house
[__] are you gonna break your mouth
before I know him
well he'll rob you right to your face
he'll just ask for some money no he he
didn't never rob me no I don't he's too
old now to do all of that [__] but you
know we did that crazy [__] when we was
kids what did you go to prison for
you've been to prison yeah I went to
jail for selling drugs selling drugs
here's here's the only question that
I've thought of ahead of time that I've
asked so far I've thought of other ones
but this is the first one what do people
get wrong about prison you watch TV
about prison people talk about prison
you were there what's what what did they
get wrong how is it different from what
everybody says
or is it not what do people say about it
horrible yeah you know what makes me mad
about people today like people getting
jumped constantly in the in the shower I
didn't see all of that yeah what makes
me mad about people today that go to
prison and you know
um I I did I did all my crime when I was
young the ones who who wants who thinks
they're at a hotel in prison yeah they
have the audacity to complain uh you
wouldn't be in this situation if you
wasn't in [__] if you didn't commit a
crime right so I'm not saying you go and
you beat them and you mistreat them
they're still human beings sure but like
they have the right to write in if like
my son was my son was a correction
officer right uh in Indiana and the the
the things people are right in one guy
wrote in and tried to sue the state of
Indiana and my son and said my son
knowingly came to work with Covey and
gave him covet
and sued well he tried he tried I didn't
go anywhere but just dumb [__] like that
did they write grievances did he give
him no my son fell out time he got
coveted them [__] gave my son
Covey right yeah prison and covet not a
good time yeah it wasn't a good time so
my son got covered when my son caught
covet when people was dropping dead and
we wasn't even when when Trump was
denying covet was real right he caught
that [__]
yes when they picked him up from the
house from from the jail I lived across
the street from the jail they called me
they was like come get your son he's not
feeling well so I get up there his eyes
is bloodshot red and I was like and I
kind of touched I was like he he's hot
he's like you should take him to the
house I'm not picking up no hot [__] I
said y'all better call 9-1-1 so they
they call 9-1-1 they don't say [__] they
jump out the back of the Amazon with the
Hazmat suit on scared the [__] out of me
like Breaking Bad threw his ass in the
ambulance and everybody get back and
asked me to hold his jacket I said I
want this [__] Jackie you better
throw that [__] in that with y'all
and I didn't see myself for three weeks
you didn't want his cover jacket I
didn't know yeah we didn't know that's
what I'm saying I couldn't even open his
eyes and when he did it was like his
eyes was on fire and I was like what the
[__] is wrong with you they rolled him
out of the jail in his uniform in a
rollaway chair and parked him on a curve
like he was like he was trash well I
stood there and waited for the ambulance
but I stayed back I was like I'm not
picking him up he ain't getting my
[__] what y'all do to him it was
so funny because now that my son is okay
the prison was hollering out of the jail
I hope you die you're fat [__] cause I
didn't like my son anyway because all
this was happening across from the
prison where they no no it was happening
in the prison so they could see after
Wonder so they was all yellow and I was
like why they don't like you well my son
I think my son was an [__] but my son
followed the rules you couldn't get him
to do nothing or Break The Rules he took
his job serious but that all along with
yellow you died your fat [__] and they
rolled him off and he was gone for three
weeks and he came back 40 pounds lighter
oh my God oh my goodness well I'm glad
he's okay oh he's fine now he eat covet
now he sprinkles it on us yes he don't
lose any weight so that's one of the
prison things is that there's like good
guards bad guards there's deals getting
made you're trading uh goods and you
know cigarettes and stuff is that all
true that's true my son said my son have
some funny prison stories one time he
told me said they caught one guard on on
tape and um they asked her they said are
you smuggling stuff into the jail so
they was finding her right and she said
I'm not why you keep taking a prison in
the mop cloth she said I'm not smuggling
anything in the jail I'm sucking dick
but that's what she was doing she was
there sucking all the prisoners dicks
for what
I don't know she likes sucking dick and
she wasn't that cute so she figured she
had as many many she wanted so she went
she got the job to suck dick
can we please
dude I don't understand a woman's just
like God I gotta suck a lot of dick how
do I do it I know I'll become a prison
guard and just tell like where it'll get
around like meet me in the broom closet
and a broom club for no Goods or
anything just I For the Love of the Game
my son had the funniest [__] prison
store he used to come home and tell me
that crap I would laugh till I piss on
myself sometimes
no yes
yes okay when you were there did you
this is a dumb question but did you
absolutely hate it was it the worst
um
it was just you couldn't go anywhere it
was a bunch of lesbian stuff going down
and I was in prison you know I went to
jail real young like 8 17. yeah so I
couldn't understand that it's not juvie
you're wearing regular no but when crack
when crack hit America they and it's
turned violent they changed going to
jail from the age of 18 to 17. oh wow
because so many and then when when crack
first came to America you could go to
jail for crack and have a bun that day
it was so bad they wasn't letting drugs
dealer back out on the street you had to
apply for a bond so when I finally I I
got in trouble for selling crack and
then I ended up on probation I violated
my probation but while I was there it
was just a bunch of lesbian stuff you
like people I went to school I was like
why are you gay what ain't nothing else
in here to do well I don't want about
eating my [__] prison game yeah prison
game was a bunch of that yeah and that
was the first time I ever seen a
hermaphrodite now that scared the [__]
out of me uh her man are we doing
hermaphrodite I'm I'm pronouncing it
wrong to see if we still use that term
it's a person who has both sets of
genitalia yes okay okay so I said I'm 50
years old so that's what it was called
when I was in prison oh I don't know she
actually think we're not sure but it's
not like an obvious mistake I think
you're in the clear yeah so that was the
first time I've ever seen a woman like
that yeah and she would show it to her
and every she would [__] everybody and
she also had three nipples well I swear
my hand to God this lady had three
[__] nipples
she had a nipple in both spot and she
had a nipple growing at the bottom and
she loves to show it I don't know she
had three nipples and she was a
hermaphrodite I had never seen it and
I'm young and I'm like well why you
gotta it was a little dick that didn't
grow all the way out yeah and they never
cut it off
sure and it wasn't her click because she
had that too
and three nips and she had three nipples
this is a hard area to Riff on I'm gonna
tell you
well I'm just telling you what I saw but
she but she [__] everybody in jail yes
I fought a lot when I was in there like
physical fights for what
um did you feel like you had to see
that's another prison thing like you
have to fight you can't take any [__]
well you can't take any [__] so what
does that mean
some I'm in prison and some dude slaps
my food out of my tray I don't be
forever picked on unless you [__]
fight back unless I you gain some
respect right then right then like I
can't like plan it and be like I can't
like my food's on the ground like all
right we'll see who's laughing tomorrow
no none of that [__] I have to do it
right let me ask you this
he slaps out of my hand I'm picturing a
weird white supremacist guy big
[__] he slaps out and I fight
him and I lose did I still gain some
respect
a little bit with an ass whipping okay
better than uh just taking the
disrespect I think it's better than
taking a disrespect because I'm gonna
lose but I'm at least I'm gonna like
flail around and what if I do something
crazy like I pee on him or something
you might gain a girl or boyfriend
which way is it Mike I don't know how
you like him Pete
I just don't know if you mean like okay
let's get off that subject that's a
weird one but it's true that you have to
fight and not I mean you have to defend
yourself and what was the first fight
you got in in prison
I had so many but I the one I remember
is like this crackhead came in out the
three days later kind of like mentally I
would say someone was wrong with him
yeah and I was on the phone back in
those days you could talk on the phone
and if you wanted to extend the call I
think you just Mash a button and they
keep going but they keep charging you by
the minutes
and I was on the phone for a really long
time and uh I think she wanted me to get
off the phone and so I we got into it so
the next day while I'm on the phone
somebody uh well I'm on the phone she'd
go upstairs and she pull out all my
shampoo and [__] oh my throw all my [__]
around in my room and so
um so the cells are just opened during
well during the day they open at night
they lock everybody in with their
roommates okay so you could be in your
room you could be in your room if you
wanted but you weren't there you're on
the phone so she doesn't [__] with your
brother so somebody told me to turn
around so she tells me she says um [__]
somebody said Pat she's standing behind
you you know turning around she got a
ink pen and so I turn around and me and
this [__] get the fight and she was
tall she probably was your height and
you see how short I am and I was a lot
smaller I've never fought anybody to the
point where I was like guys can y'all
please break us up I was so [__]
tired of fighting this big old [__]
cause every time I had to jump up and
grab my hair and we I was going to throw
her over the pole it was like you know
in prison got her upstairs and you got a
downstairs yeah like a mall yeah so I
was gonna throw her over the balancer in
my mind said if you do that you ain't
never getting out of here that [__]
don't make it right and so I pulled it
back on the part and I'm just hitting
this crackhead and hitting this crack
and she's not feeling it just keep
coming back for more and I was like what
the [__] is the guard but the guard up
there in the window just watching the
[__] fight so finally they come over
and break this [__] up right and then
they throw us outside uh on the
basketball court on different sides and
you know I'm in Georgia mosquitoes ate
all ass up
did she have the ink pen as a weapon
yeah as a weapon she was going to stab
you with it they said she was gonna stab
me so I turned around just started
swinging because
yeah that's scary because you wasn't
gonna put your [__] hand on me in
jail the whole respect issue
well I was young back in the day I
didn't give a [__] you know when you
young you don't think you can die all
you do is [__] fight you at the fool
yeah and that that was my whole
mentality the first 10 minutes of the
movie Creed
no it's not out yet Creed one
well I can't remember that foot back P
God damn I'm gonna see if he's in prison
he's fighting a bunch of people and then
uh the mom from the college I know we
got to go but can I tell you we ain't
gonna go we're just going to go to the
minerals we're not done oh let me tell
you what I saw last night what was that
movie Felicia Rashad
cocaine bear because if it was Creed I'd
be like you should I agree I'm going to
see Creed and I don't go to the movie I
saw cocaine ballet you saw cocaine bear
did you love it [__] no oh
that was the stupidest [__] movie and
I hate to say that tell me I was my you
know what it looks the previews look so
[__] good to cocaine Bears yeah it
was a dumbest [__] then it scared me end
up being kind of like a scary movie it
was scary so it's based on a true story
only part was true was the cocaine got
dropped out of a plane and I think a
bear did it and died yeah but he did it
and died but they're like what if he got
really high in Guild people and that's
what he did yeah it was a dumbest [__] I
mean I've seen people on cocaine but
nobody do this much cocaine in one day
this [__] was eating kilos of
cocaine yeah I mean it never turned into
the second day the third day oh this
bear ain't like 12 [__] kilos of
cocaine and [__] possible one kilo
would have killed him also why does he
want to kill everybody if he's feeling
high on cocaine shouldn't he have just
tried to have next to the lady bear and
lost his erection yeah what did he did
he try to get some dick or [__]
whatever he was try to get a gold
necklace or something or a disco I I
don't know Pete but it what I'm riffing
off what people usually do on cocaine oh
well spending money it was a dumbest
[__] it was their erections I wanted to
laugh but I was like what the [__] is
that then it got legit scary
well when he was ripping people kneecaps
off and [__] yeah that's not fun and I
mean but I'm sitting there knowing
somebody who's dead with cocaine I don't
give a [__] if you as a bear you can't
eat no block of cocaine and just be
running around hunting on people this
goddamn bit like 12 things a CO I mean
duffel bags of cocaine it's a lot of
cocaine it's gonna kill a bear and he
wasn't there today
him and his kids was on cocaine oh no so
I guess they couldn't kill the bear in
the movie you couldn't care the bad mood
because of Peter was like oh my God you
could at least sit in the bath to rehab
[Music]
I'm assuming that's what be more like
more like uh their agent named Peter was
saying there's going to be a cocaine
bear too I mean this is clearly gonna
make money well I went to go see it it
looked so good I was like but it wasn't
what I was expecting yeah I tried to
watch Brendan Fraser and the whale last
night I'm not saying it's not good but
it was so heavy that I was like he
dropped a key and he's trying to get it
with his like pincher claw thing yeah
have you seen the whale he's a he's in a
big big big big big big big big
prosthetic uh fat suit
he got swallowed by a whale no no it's
called the whale and he's a big dude and
that's why it's called the whale but
like around the part where he's just
trying to pick up a key well I can't
pick up my keys well I don't want to see
a movie of that either
so what you was feeling sorry because he
couldn't he couldn't he couldn't pick up
his [__] thing
[Music]
what fat people don't tie their shoes
that's why they buy slip-ons oh my God
will you stop it you're killing me so
Brendan frasian is fat and what he's
really really big and he couldn't pick
up a key and it wasn't that it was that
horrible but I was like I'm about to go
to bed I don't want to have dreams that
I can't pick up a key for eight hours it
was just it was a heavy movie but I
laughed at myself I was like what did
you expect what did you think it was
going to be is it out in the theaters
you can rent you can buy it it's also in
theaters yeah oh I might have to check
that one out yeah it'll it'll solve the
problem I'm fat I can't bend over it
sometimes he's like not nine years I
mean he's he's a he's real big he's like
Gilbert Grape remember What's Eating
Gilbert Grape yeah I remember that movie
yeah it was like that was a woman right
that's Gilbert grape's mom what's she
eating that was a better better tell she
was a very big woman that's the one they
told her on the side of the house to get
her out that's right but in the wheel
did they ever put her on a diet I don't
remember because it wasn't really about
her was it
I'll say in the whale it shows him
eating a lot
because you know did he lose the weight
I don't know I I left around the key
part
he was at the theater no no I bought it
I was home alone because Val my wife
doesn't want to watch it so I was like I
want to watch this I'm not saying it's
not good I'm just saying it was it was
very heavy it was a little bit like
cocaine bear was scary will is sadder
than they made it cocaine bear was it
was it scared me in some points but it
was not as funny as it looked like it
was going to be right and um I wanted to
see a little bit more story than the
Bear Just ripping everybody apart yeah
so you know what what are his dreams
what are his hopes
I just wanted it didn't do it for me I
understand but I I we went you know I'm
uh 43 I have a daughter people like you
want to see cocaine bear I'm like no
just just flat out no I'm gonna watch
half of the whale
well I'm gonna go check out the whale
because you know I want to get back into
going to movie theaters yeah you know
and then I get to AMC here sure
um
cap out they [__] nachos was the the
cheese was cold
and they had no Survivor skills how to
make them hot I'm like ma'am go go pop
it in the microwave go soak it in some
hot water give me my [__] nacho I'm
going to the bathroom and run some hot
water over it
I'm sorry but if nacho cheese isn't hot
that's just a that's a that's a hate
crime that's an assault oh it was
[__] horrible yeah no it's terrible
all right let's go to the mid rolls and
then when we come back I want to hear a
little bit about your show and how it
happened the Miss Pat show okay which
I'm still hoping to come on you coming
Pete I got you all right we'll be right
back
part of the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at Sunday Sunday lawn care I don't know
if you're like me you love spring but
you may not love figuring out how the
heck I'm gonna add the heck how the heck
do you take care of your yard I have no
clue does anyone else just stand there
in the store wondering where to start
feeling intimidated and afraid to ask
somebody at the store wearing an apron
to help you that's where Sunday lawn
care comes in Sunday is everything you
need to get the lawn you have dreamed of
we're talking healthy we're talking Lush
we're talking easy to do no-brainer
stuff they take all the guesswork out of
it so this spring Go to
getsunday.com weird and enter your
address to get a customized plan it's so
cool they find where you are and they
give you a customized plan created just
for your lawn not everyone your lawn and
the conditions of your home no trips to
the store are hauling heavy bag since
they ship straight to your home you just
need a hose to apply Sunday it's
actually fun you screw it on you spray
it on it goes on the hose Leela actually
loves helping me do it we spray it
everywhere you can fertilize your whole
lawn in less time than it takes to watch
an episode of your favorite TV show and
they only use ingredients you feel good
about you can feel good about and you do
feel good about that means no harsh
chemicals no long waiting periods or
trying to keep your kids and your pets
off the lawn simply apply let it dry and
you're back to just enjoying your yard
which is what you should do Sunday is
easy and affordable some lawn care
services cost more than fifteen hundred
dollars a year but Sunday's full season
plans start at just a hundred and nine
dollars and Sunday is offering weirdos
our listeners 20 Off full season plans
start at just 109 and you can get 20 off
when you visit
getsunday.com weird at checkout that's
20 off your custom plan at
getsunday.com
weird this episode
is brought To Us by betterhelp the show
is sponsored by better help Getting to
Know Yourself can be a lifelong process
especially because we're always growing
and changing I've sought out therapy in
times of transition whether it's moving
whether it's changing a job situation
whether it's changing a relationship
that's often what I've craved and needed
talk therapy more than other times in my
life and therapy is about deepening your
self-awareness and your understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or why we react the way we do until
we talk through things we say this on
the show all the time talk therapy is
one of those things that is greater than
the sum of its parts it seems like two
people talking in a room but when it's a
professional who knows how to listen how
to actively listen and to guide and coax
you into the right areas it is
absolutely life-changing and better help
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are
it's never been easier therapy has
absolutely changed my life it's changed
Val's life obviously for the better or I
wouldn't be talking about it right now
know it's it's like a catharsis it's
guidance it's everything that you're
that you're hoping it will be I promise
talk therapy can really make a huge
difference in your life especially at a
time of transition or change and when
aren't we in a time of change if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire or get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
discover your potential with better help
visit
betterhelp.com weirdo today to get 10
off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p
betterhelp.com weirdo
support your mind your mental health and
show some support for the show it means
a lot go to betterhealth.com
weirdo last but not least we're brought
To Us by our friends at ritual
multivitamin you guys know I record
these intros often when I'm traveling on
the road and I always demonstrate that
ritual I take lots of different
supplements at lots of different times
in my life but ritual are the only ones
that make it into the carry-on I never
travel without them I never miss a day I
take their uh probiotic and I take their
daily men's multivitamin and I have the
doctor checkups to show this stuff works
it gets into your system you don't just
pee it out I hear a lot of people
dismissing multivitamins because it just
goes through your system ritual has a
delayed release formula so it doesn't
break down until it's in your lower
intestine which is how your body can
absorb that stuff all that stuff you
know what I'm saying the nutrients the
nutrients in rituals case the traceable
nutrients they'll tell you where these
nutrients are coming from which is
incredible able added to which they have
Prebiotic post-biotic and probiotics in
one in their symbiotic plus which I take
every single day we always talk about
how important gut health is it's
basically like a second brain and
keeping that healthy is so important for
so many major body functions and your
overall Wellness so you can talk fantasy
football with your friends all day but
asking for health advice not the move
ritual takes the guesswork out of the
vitamin game their multivitamin for men
is based on science to help fill common
nutrient gaps in their diet and level up
your nutrition your nutrient goals it's
an all-around win it is scientifically
developed multivitamin of high quality
ingredients in clean bioavailable forms
ritual is your new type of two a days
help supporting heart health with
omega-3 DHA to normal muscle function
and normal immune function with vitamin
D3 this small step can have a huge Major
Impact it's made traceable because
knowing where your nutrients come from
is just as important as what they're for
it's vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free major allergen free and if
as if that wasn't enough they're minty
Essence in every bottle keeps things
tasting fresh and makes taking your
Maltese every day actually enjoyable
enjoyable so essential for men is a
quality multivitamin from a company you
can actually trust and get this ritual
is offering weirdos 10 off during your
first three months visit ritual.com
weird to start ritual or add essential
for men to your subscription today
that's ritual.com weird do your body a
favor do your gut a favor and show your
support of the show it means a lot
alright everybody let's get back to this
path
and we're instantly back tell me a
little bit about how the misspatch show
came about I mean we we were just in
prison fighting a woman who was on uh
crack cocaine and she's going to stab
you with a patent it's a long way from
uh having your show be Emmy nominated
going into the third season yes what is
going on
um how did it happen I I honestly
podcast made it happen I did I get I did
Mark Maron podcast and uh right after
that I need broken and from Mark Maron
podcast I sold a book and I sold I mean
I got audition I mean people called me
in and said hey I want to give you a
book no really yeah at the same book and
a show at the same time so but it still
took five years to get the show on TV
from this podcast you'll get a 10-minute
spot at the belly room okay we're good
I'm looking forward to it Peter already
had that tonight
I can't even give you what you don't
already have so you did Marin you told
your story they were like please put
that in a book then you said then you
did Rogan and someone's like please make
that into a show I will say this I did
Ari and a lady heard me say I think I
can get you a book deal well we had
started working on the book deal and we
released Marin and then the uh the
Publishers came along and bought the
book but at that time Hollywood started
I had six interviews after that to come
on and just talk about you know just try
to see if I had anything yeah and um I
signed with one company nine months
later that didn't work out any imagine
for TV shows TV shows imagine Ron Howard
company pick me up yeah and said I think
we can develop something with you so
they brought Lee Daniel on the project
and
um we it took a little time I went
through a few writers I finally got a
writer that understood the projects and
then we wrote a pilot we sold it to Hulu
Hulu shot it said hell no and we waited
how was that don't don't glass over that
that must have been painful that wasn't
painful no no I mean I come from a
background where I'm I'm conditioned to
hear no when you say yeah that's when I
like what the [__] you say
so that's what you don't know what to do
with it it's a protective mode for me
sure because so many times in life
people have let me down so I expect for
you to say no so when you say yes
I'm shocked right so when Hulu picked it
up and they shot it and you know it
wasn't they felt like it wasn't for
their platform but I have to I always
have to thank Hulu because they helped
us create such a great pilot yeah when
we took it out again and bet plus looked
at it they automatically bought it wow
so it was the same pilot you didn't
reshoot no we didn't reshoot the power
didn't it briefly go to Fox there too
well well I tell you after Lee Daniel
what's called uh at the time uh Empire
was the biggest thing on TV so Fox gave
me the deal and when the third writer
came along he told them that I should be
on streaming and I should eat shouldn't
censor me so we took it over to Hulu oh
because Fox was gonna be you know how
Fox a lot less [__] and yeah
all of that I mean even with the even
with the boys even with the content you
know we did this second I thought you
said cuntis and I'm going to be honest
because I was like you can't say
[__] and you're like you can't
say cuntis but you were saying contest
yeah content so you know like I did an
abortion episode right where I'm in my
I'm in my late 50s I'm in my I'm 50
years old and I get an abortion well I'm
still married Fox ain't going for that
right right so you know T some TV just
like to tie [__] up in a bowl we don't
do that over there we if we talking
about something we gonna talk about it
right right the way real people should
talk about it right so
um you know we went to Hulu and after
they shot it they said no and BT plus
picked it up and at first I was a little
worried there was a new platform I had
never heard of bet plus yeah and
um after doing some research and I just
told my co-creator I said look
if it's good
people gonna come two things and I said
this all the time two thing in this
world I've never seen a commercial for
is crack and Waffle House and they're
both doing fine they're both gonna sell
they've been doing fine for years so I
said if we put crack and put a little
cheese and eggs and they crack we good
we we got we got a recipe
and that's what we did and then each
year it catch on more and more and more
right and didn't you do multiple Seasons
like what didn't they buy multiple
Seasons or something's going on where
you got picked up for two seasons yeah I
did I did season two and then in the
middle that they came in and they did
season three and so at after season one
I ended up getting overall deal with
Viacom and VT plus wow good for you yeah
it's incredible and how has your life
changed I mean this is a new level of
success you've been poor you've been
breaking into houses to steal diapers
excellent but you know I've always had
money I sold crack I I did a lot of
crazy [__] in my life to get money you
mean you weren't hurting when you were
selling crack you were doing okay I was
doing really [__] well I made a lot
of [__] money I mean you really were
I made a lot of [__] money where were
you in the in the food chain of drug
dealing you weren't just working the
street then you were Distributing no I
was making a lot of money you were
making the deals with the importers or
the people what people are making crack
people cook crack well I cooked you cook
your own you cook your own crack yes you
could it's no such thing as you cook the
pot it's the white people drug right and
you turn it into crack right do you know
that you can get more time okay then you
can powder cocaine absolutely which is
uh institutionalized racism it's like
normalized racism because powder is for
you we don't use powder that's right
black people smoke crack yeah I don't
like that I'm the example of whiteness
but I mean I'm just sitting there I'm
sitting across from yeah if there was
another white guy we could have gestured
well I could say her name is going
skiing if you know what I mean what she
does a lot of coke oh yeah I don't
believe that just to listen to all these
podcasts do you think she's doing that I
think she's owning Starbucks yes that's
what I think she's doing regular Italian
Italiano if she was doing uh cocaine she
wouldn't have no teeth she is really
nice that's right we know that for a
fact is that your wife no that's Katie
oh
so that's her official
official no that's Katie I didn't mean
it as an insult Katie I ain't gonna ask
you if you're a boy or girl not in this
Society
it is a afab assigned female at Birth
and she's been our producer for over 10
years oh great Katie nice to meet you so
you were making a lot of money making
your own crack I was not making my own
crack you said you cooked it yeah you
cooked it
yes you got the cocaine here's a
question why make it into crack
because black people didn't do powder we
care about our nose that's why because
you'd rather smoke something than well
because you can Freebase the powder
can't you it was just not it's marketing
really like it just wasn't really
introduced I don't know if the high was
better I don't know because I've never
I've never done you know cocaine or
crack right but it was just something
you know
black people wasn't into right when I
when I as far as I can remember back it
was always crack
which I'm not an expert on the history
but it did seem like in a deliberate
attack on impoverished black communities
it's like Let's do let's let's flood it
in and make a lot of arrests and like
you said you when you get I think you
gave the black community something
or the poor the poor black people wasn't
used to which was money they was able to
buy better things do better things live
a little bit better you mean the dealers
the dealers and then that's when you saw
the killing came along it was all set up
right you know because I mean think
about this oh you I don't know how you
are but the black father was never
removed from the household until crack
hit the black community tell me you
never heard we didn't have a daddy
everybody had a daddy
black man went to work all the time as
soon as crack hit the black community it
destroyed the black homes hmm and you
feel like that was intentional I mean
you wouldn't be the only one well we as
black people feel like that was
intentional right it was by Design yes I
mean the same way as gentrification when
they come in and they want you to the
black people is like it's in Baltimore
in Atlanta we need that we need that
City you know so they can control the
[__] state right you get it you get
all those poor black people out of
Atlanta that's a big ass conquer this
other state right right and it's also
like the city this it seems like there's
this belief that there has to be
somebody at the bottom so whoever's at
the bottom keep them at the bottom is
that part of the theory it's like let's
because you it was already a community
that was struggling right yeah and then
you flood it to keep it down you know
what I mean like it make it worse you
know I just saw this thing on TV I'm
driving a truck I don't know that's how
this thing on Tick Tock and this guy was
speaking I don't know if y'all ever seen
it but he was saying uh it was a white
dude telling the story he said rich
people come into po neighborhood and by
buildings and leave them condemned so
they can drive down the value of the
neighborhood so if they drive it so low
they could continue to buy or they'll
buy [__] and Let It Go raggedy
and they'll drive down the value of the
neighborhood and when they do that they
can get everything in that neighborhood
for free so if you really did your
research on a lot of those condemned
buildings in the ghetto they're owned by
sometimes one company or one person wow
and as they do that they bring down the
value to say oh this is a ghetto and
then the city just start giving you [__]
well hey we'll give you this we give you
this we give you this to fix it up right
when it was always somebody behind it
driving down the value of the black
community that's Sinister yeah that's
really devilish welcome to America
welcome way into the camera please
welcome welcome to America with Miss Pat
I mean it's dark [__] and you do you
tackle stuff like that on the show I've
seen I haven't seen every episode but
you go after uh police uh violence
murder all that stuff we have not did
one police brutality have we there was a
joke about it oh
black people don't buy lottery tickets
[Music]
oh I said I was it was in my uh
monologue I said black people um I
thought you said on the airplane
because then the woman oh yeah the woman
said next it was that was actually a bit
so when I was creating this show I moved
to Plainfield Indiana and I lived in
that little white neighborhood and I
used to I used to Fly Southwest all the
time and so I like to talk to people
just to see what they thinking I don't
judge you if you if you vote or believe
in whatever it's just a conversation and
I think as Americans it's the things
that we could we we should do more of we
can get a better understanding I don't
say you racist because you vote for
Trump I don't want you to think of
something is wrong with me because I
vote a certain way I think no matter
which way we vote or believe in we
should at the end yeah we should be able
to respect each other I agree so when I
used to Fly Southwest I would always say
it was Southwest the place where you can
have those conversations yes yes that's
right so I was like a plus right get on
a plane first and I would always block
off a seat
for
a white person oh I'm not lying for
somebody that did not look like that I
would talk to on a daily basis usually
it would strongly be white means every
time every now that I'll get a vocal
white woman yeah but I wouldn't block
off that deceit act like I'm waiting on
somebody and as they come down the aisle
I catch my Victim and once I mean and I
you know I start off as a regular
conversation it would get into life or
we'll get into religion because I'm a
night I'm an easy person to talk to yeah
you are and so that's how that whole bit
came about
was the lottery bit with yeah the
lottery and said you said that to
someone yeah that was I made a bit out
of that yeah but it's based on something
you said on the Southwest flight tell
the people what you said because I know
what you said but they don't know I
can't remember the big you said well I
don't want to say it but don't say I'll
say it you said black people don't buy
lottery tickets they just wait oh the
police to shoot your child uh and then
maybe you'll get a million dollar
settlement yeah and then and then they
attacks it yep that wasn't that it's a
very dark thing but it's a way of
addressing something it's very true we
they kill our kids you know the police
you know and and I look I try to look at
it both ways I say this to police
officer
think about if that was your child
somebody was shooting would you want
your child to be treated the way you see
these black I don't give a [__] if he
did run from me I don't give a [__]
you're a police officer your whole thing
is to take a man alive and make sure you
okay too you know I could see if
somebody's trying to harm you but God
damn you shoot somebody for having a
cell phone in their hand 55 times right
that's a problem right but no but this
what's wrong with this country on this
world I believe nobody ever put
theirself in that situation that's right
that's that's the core of the problem is
we we forgot that we belong to each
other yes so would you want somebody to
treating your child in a way right would
you want somebody beating the dog [__]
out of your child shooting your child
like that so when when I made that whole
bit and I opened it up with that because
I tried to give the other two writers
that but they wouldn't listen to me but
I'm like we can be funny but we can also
be sending a message but we ain't gotta
hit Miss past show no is not a teaching
moment for white people it's a teaching
moment for all of us even when I did the
non-binary episode it was because my
daughter is gay and my other daughter
had a friend like that and I had never
heard of the word non-binary and when
she said she was Nutri gender what is it
oh I'm sorry yeah yes pouring out the
shampoo we're back in prison yeah so I
mean it's it's just something that you
know it's it's hard conversation we yeah
but humor can help
when you do it funny I'm sure the
Southwest flight was the same you can
you have a specific Talent spider
of uh addressing things in your tiny
baby little spider you should have
killed it
oh he's he's definitely hobbling
I went like that that was huge for him
it was like a tsunami in three weeks he
gonna be so big but anyway keep going
I would just try to give you the
compliment that you are so funny there's
a lot of things that you can tackle and
address for a lot of people to watch and
enjoy yes that that it's very hard to do
nobody can do that very very few people
can do it and you're very special in
that way we're almost out of time which
I hate
but what do you think about God real
quick
yeah God we talked about God tricking
you a lot well what is your god do you
think life is over when we die do do you
pray tell me tell me
I don't I never read the Bible
well you know it's man-made this is a
way to control the population of people
on Earth that's true and then I believe
some of it is real but
um I do think that something's bigger
than all of us out in the universe do
you think you've been here before I
think all of us I think we're recycled
yeah I agree I because you know what I
was looking on Facebook and so they have
this thing where they show you that
people before you you ever seen that and
they have all of these famous black
actors people before you yeah like like
to show you you've been here before and
then they'll show you how people in
Africa really looked
Jasmine what does that mean no no no no
no they show you like they show you a
picture of Denzel Washington damn a
hundred years ago they'll show you
somebody that was straight out of a
trial they look just like Denzel
Washington yeah same face the same face
so I do think we all are recycle yeah
yeah so I mean God's running out of face
ideas I'll give them out uh yeah I don't
know that [__] face again and if
you're gonna redo one Denzel is a good
choice yeah but I know that dude at 300
years ago people were like man that's a
symmetrical phase but I I truly believe
we all been here before I think we all
recycle yeah I I don't know I I don't
think it's a hell on Heaven I think we
just out there floating come back I mean
and I think we all come back that's got
to make you less afraid to die though
you're just like this is the only game
in town and we're just gonna keep doing
it I accepted it I was I have accepted
we're all gonna die but I don't know if
I don't know if hell is real I don't
know if heaven is real I you know when I
was little you had the last step on the
wall I just pray that God has upgraded
that dinner to a cheek for laying Heaven
cause I know I'm coming
nobody want them shitty grapes that was
on that plate on the Last Supper nobody
wants to eat that Jesus this is your
last summer with no [__]
preservatives in in it nobody wants that
I just hope he's a I hope it's a yellow
brick road of fast food and we can just
[__] live there you go but I truly
believe that we all been here before I
love that let me ask you this our final
question uh can you tell me this flew by
the way you're such a talent and such a
pleasure to talk to and I really hope I
get to be on your show only to hang out
with you you can cut me out I know I've
been I've been cutting the scenes out no
no I've been streaming hey we gotta get
Pete Lee on this show we gotta get
petely on this [__] holds not petely get
that out of here I don't want I don't
know why I'm thinking of Pete Lee Pete
Holmes yeah yeah we got to get Pete
Holmes on this show and you work with
Patrick wash yeah that's my boy yes so
Patrick is a writer on the show I know
and he says it's a true and he's right
he's very proud of it you know what
I mean we brought pressure over the BET
and
we're here BT plus he is just fell in
love I love me some Patrick you should
like if you're ever bored listen to him
on this podcast because he tells these
stories you wouldn't believe really he
told me he did stand up before and he's
done it a couple times yeah yeah for
some reason he's not he doesn't have the
bug to like do it all the time but when
he does it I've seen him do it it's very
good he's very funny good not a surprise
the question I have for you here at the
end Kate Holmes not Pete Lee Yes Pete
Holmes is coming on my show and not Pete
Coryell I don't know Davidson
there are other people Peter pay not
Peter Pan although I've been known to go
out a few Windows what does that mean
listen
could mean so many things and none of
them are good okay
um can you tell me the time in your life
you laugh the hardest it doesn't have to
be a great story but if you're like
worried you're gonna throw up you're
laughing so hard tears going down your
face maybe you're a kid maybe somebody
fell maybe somebody farted maybe
somebody slipped maybe your brother got
shot at
ah I'll tell you the story my mama uh
had one leg because she lost her leg of
diabetes very early and so when she used
to get a social security check once a
month we didn't have a car at the time
so she would catch a cab because there
was no Uber making these days to the
bank have the man sit there all day to
the bank to the check deposit in the
bank it was a social security check and
a lot of time it didn't come to after 12
but she had catch the cab at eight
o'clock and just wait here just wait
here just wait and I'm like and I'm
saying to myself I'm young I'm like well
[__] just go to the bank at 12 30. you
know the check is going to be there yeah
so we were sitting outside the bank it
was an African Guy and um by the time we
get back home yeah I think the cab is 75
my mom probably got six hundred dollars
here she refused to pay that man he made
the cab idling out front the bank 75
worth yes it probably was more than that
I don't remember this is not a good day
Central decision thank you but we
already [__] poor
she get a weed and take her back and she
don't want to pay to me so the man
called the police so by this time I
don't got my mama wheelchair out and you
know because she she didn't have a leg
on and put in the wheelchair the police
like knock on the door and he said ma'am
you you you jumped out of a cab and ran
my mom's like how the [__] I jump out of
a [__] cab I got one [__]
late police officer so the police the
police said but Mom get a man this money
I ain't getting my [__] thing
yo he tilt her wheelchair back and say
well off the jail you go my mama
snatched that money in her [__] leg
and threw it at that cab driver
he tilted her back like this is the
easiest way to take a person to prison
ever yeah he about to roll it down the
steps you know you just can't you got to
tip the wheelchair back
he tilt that chair back and boy about to
take her to that police car [__] she
pulled that money away from up on that
fake socks and leg with that sock on it
so quick ah Hollow about about five
months later I call a cab and the cab
job pick me up right he's like where's
your crazy ass mama I said man she died
oh my God
can I also say in your mom's defense
this is the 80s uh this was the 90s 90s
any time before Uber cabs were the worst
it was so hard to get a cab so that's
why she probably wanted this guy no not
in Atlanta we lived in Atlanta it's hard
to get one in New York oh I don't even
mean for the race reasons I just mean
calling a cab
you know it was really big in Atlanta so
it was not everybody wasn't catching the
cab you know right people was getting
asses on the bus but she couldn't get on
the bus because she had a wheelchair
right so right okay we anytime we call
them you know something that's hard to
get a [__] cab but right that time
she was gonna take her ass to jail and I
kept trying to say mama while we here at
the bay it was like two hours
we was in that car sweating we have no
money for food we was hot as [__] and my
mama kept having me go in the bank and
asked about the check out there yet the
chicken oh my God
he did a wheelie he made your mom do a
wheelie in a wheelchair well she's about
to take her black ass to jail that day
boy she gave that cab driver hit money
and he left the meter running while he
called the police yeah that's a smart
cab driver yeah and she and I think she
was out of like a hundred and some books
and her check was on like 600 or
something she's like I guess you
[__] ain't gonna eat for the
rest of the month I didn't give a [__] I
thought that was a funny [__] watching
her go to jail
oh my God Miss Pat thank you people can
watch Miss Pat show on BT plus the pat
down is your podcast thank you for being
here Season Three is out now it's out
now it's out right now and uh would this
is how we end the show the guest says
keep it crispy it's just the catchphrase
would you grace us with a keep it crispy
uh keep it crispy but not fried crispy
thank you for giving us the full meal
not the crumbles you gave us the full
meal today thank you it was awesome
I'm gonna help you get out of that thing
that's magic mine that was a little
coffee drink that's a little water
Nirvana Water you don't you can take
them with you okay
[Music]
oh yeah